man I haven't done one of these things
in a minute it's been a while man let's
let's get it rolling huh hey what is
going on YouTube yes it's been a minute
I haven't done one of these videos in a
while we'll check it out you guys
already know I've been doing something
called the genius brain podcast and
that's basically what this channel is
well you know sometimes on genius brain
I can't wait for somebody to come in so
I could talk about a toc-toc ik TOC ik
topic I want to talk about and you know
if you guys don't already know
especially if you out in LA then you
really disconnected but today's topic
we're gonna be talking about the passing
of Nipsey Hussle and on top of that
Kodak blacks disrespect towards the man
and his widowed wife now just as a quick
refresher if you guys don't know who
Nipsey Hussle is Nipsey Hussle is an
la-based rapper that's associated with
it with the rolling 60 scripts for me I
didn't really listen to a lot and
Lipsey's music I was a fan of his in
terms of I think he did something back
in the day where he could be misquoting
this but I know jay-z bought a bunch of
his album that he was doing this like
this model where he was selling his
albums for like a hundred and something
bucks each or something don't quote me
on that but basically with that model
like it kind of made me respect him as
an artist because he was doing something
along the lines where he was showing
people that he was creating art and if
people wanted to [ __ ] with him they
would have to pay this premium price for
this product and so he wasn't really out
there trying to push a product to
everybody can become famous in that kind
of sense he wanted to really express
himself with a specific type of art
which was his music now with that being
said you know buffing a couple of his
songs here and there if she was kind of
more known especially now I think for a
lot of people who didn't know who he was
and this is me included I didn't know
about a lot of the community outreach
that he did building after-school
centers that had to do with like
technology kind of putting money back
into his community and putting his money
where his mouth is because there was a
lot of earlier interviews that I saw
where he was talking about he wanted to
invest in the real estate and kind of
put back to his community that raised
him and he was one of those rappers that
actually did that and he was a man of
his word so when he passed I think even
if you didn't listen to his music you
really [ __ ] with the guy at who he was
about and there's a lot of people out
there saying [ __ ] like name five nipsey
songs if you
really big fan of him though name five
nifty songs if you really [ __ ] with them
its Joe stupid-ass stuff it's not even
about that [ __ ] dude why can't people
just support somebody even after their
death and it's kind of sad that he's
really respected for what he's done you
know after he passed but if that's the
information that people are getting
about him now let them respect him for
who he was
I understand people out there who are
huge nipsey fans that might say stuff
like well it kind of seems a little
disrespectful because you guys are just
kind of saying [ __ ] just to gain clout
but at the same time like if his if his
name is getting bigger from for all the
good things that he's done then shut the
[ __ ] up and let it happen so after his
passing
Kodak black basically did this Instagram
Live thing where he was shooting his
shot at a Lauren London which is Nipsey
Hussle now widowed wife the wife of his
children here's where the controversy
comes in right this [ __ ] Kodak
black is such an interesting character
and I know like rappers or rappers and
people who are in the limelight they
tend to do a lot of dumb things and we
kind of give people a pass and this is a
part where I I really feel like this
little kid [ __ ] up and what I mean by
that is that when a community comes
together after somebody that is a
prominent figure in that community
passes away and everybody is trying to
ban in support of this man especially
because it makes that community look so
much better and you come in and you do
something that trashy you got to really
think twice about what you're doing you
little dumb [ __ ] clearly I'm not a black
man alright but if I were to give an
example of this it would be like when
crazy rich Asians came out and when
crazy rich Asians came out what if I
said yo don't even look at that [ __ ]
movie I bet you that [ __ ] is hot garbage
but for me I would have never said that
even if I did felt that way about that
movie because I know about the positive
movement that's that movie had on my
culture right so Kodak black this ugly
ass little [ __ ] talks about
shooting a shot to Lauren London now let
me just quote him real quick
says y'all give her a whole year he
might need a whole year to be crying and
[ __ ] for him number one I don't really
know you and I could give a [ __ ] less
about you so I would just say what I'm
gonna say you stupid you still babe how
are you gonna shoot your shot at a woman
who just lost the father to her children
if you were saying that [ __ ] in the
privacy of your home
but she still isn't right but it would
probably been smart if you just said it
to your [ __ ] friends what you did but
you put that [ __ ] out on live so you
obviously wanted people to hear it and
you thought that it was a smart thing to
say
now the trashiest thing about this kid
Kodak black is the apology that he gave
not only are you [ __ ] dumb your
apology was so insincere it was
ridiculous this is what the cat said if
I disrespected you Lauren London in any
shape or form
I am sorry sounds good right then he
goes even though I did it my see I'm not
even mad at you for what you said or I
don't even think people are mad at you
for what you said people are mad at you
because they listen to your music and
they didn't realize how [ __ ] stupid
you are now for me I've seen your
interviews I've seen you in Iraq I heard
you speak I got a sense that you were
dumb from a mile away
you're stupid you're so stupid the
reason why you think you didn't say
anything offensive is because your Kodak
black you're the rapper and you're the
kid with a lot of money you want to
track with Bruno Mars and all of a sort
of [ __ ] so because you're shooting your
shot at her you're telling her that
she's so beautiful she's so attracted
that you would be willing to date her
that that's a compliment you dumb [ __ ]
but you're so [ __ ] dumb that all you
see is that technically this these are
complements so we shouldn't be taken in
an offensive wave but you're so so so
stupid you can't see that hitting on a
woman who just lost her husband where
the whole community is still mourning
him after being slain that that would be
inappropriate you are dumb how many
times that seems stupid in this video
how many times talking about that you'd
give her a shot but she was talking
about you ugly-ass [ __ ] I'll put
it out like this bro I'm the most
attractive man on earth but I'm so
confident in how ugly you are I could
just straight-up say
you ugly you are so hideous my ugly ass
can call you ugly with mad confidence
you know what you look like codex black
looked like your evil thoughts come to
life
Kodak black look like a shadow with bad
intentions Hodag black look like he's
gonna be casted in the movie us just
play himself go that black look like you
can wear a diaper and mesh it would just
make sense you so we're looking you look
like the crackhead offspring of Flavor
Flav that's every body is coming after
you man
the game is coming after you man this
dude straight-up blamed you and the
youth you such a bad representation of
the youth even game said that you know
what all you young [ __ ] don't
even bunch in young people with this guy
because you you you're not even a part
of that you're just a dumbass
you got rapper so man you got Ti putting
out a video about you befo t I use the
word expeditiously how are you gonna get
T I so mad you gotta use him Mike Tyson
words and [ __ ] expeditiously yeah you've
been apologized expeditiously yeah I got
that Mike Tyson thesaurus I'm gonna cut
me if you and eat your children and then
after what imma do it expeditiously you
know if I were to wrap up my thoughts on
this this is kind of where people feel
like hip-hop has taken a turn for the
worse
right see I feel like this is the part
where people can really just start
putting people in check you know these
rappers musicians and even artists like
me we stay alive based on you know your
support and if any all out there right
now are backing up Kodak blacks number
one you don't understand the gravity of
the situation you don't understand the
level of disrespect and time in place
and how inappropriate that [ __ ] was and
for him this kid he doesn't get it he
still says that he didn't do anything
wrong he's just apologizing just because
everybody else is upset you dumb little
[ __ ] man you lucky you have money man
you ugly and stupid
Jesus definitely took a break when he
made us look at like a Japanese anime
supervillain issue so let me ask you
guys what are your thoughts on this do
you think that Kodak black was just
being young and then he should get a
password or do you think it's right that
people put him in check or do you think
that he was just having a conversation
with his friends and his cool personally
for me I think that he was way out of
line number one he's misrepresenting the
youth number one he was disrespectful to
a man who just passed away and that was
a huge part of his community that he
belongs to to the people that support
him number three he was super
disrespectful to his to his widowed wife
Lauren London and on top of that to his
children and his whole family and
everybody in his community the kid needs
to really think twice about his [ __ ] if
I ever see you in person
I guarantee you I ain't gonna say to
your face anybody that ugly don't give a
[ __ ] about anybody else's life I think
that much anyways guys I hope you guys
enjoyed that video if you guys want to
see more videos like this leave it in
the comments below if not
I don't really give and remember guys if
you love this short format content
you're gonna love the longer format
content even better genius brain is up
every Thursday and Sunday and remember
we're getting sponsored ads the more you
guys watch the more you guys listen into
this [ __ ] which I'm really glad that you
are liking it the better it is man I
don't have a suck dick subscribe hit
that like button and I'll see you all
next time love your mother's